You are listening to radio lab radio from w n y.
S. E. Yup.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab and today
we're gonna start this show with it with a fellow named Ben Montgomery,
a reporter for the Tampa Bay Times. He's a guy we've had on the show before.
Ben, say something. Hi, this is Ben. Okay.
Everything good? Okay, good. All right. Where we are.
Just want to know from you like what are you guys doing? How are you doing it?
What are you thinking? I'll start at the beginning. Yeah.
Start at the beginning. Tell us what you're doing.
So after the Mike Brown shooting in Ferguson,
here is growing outrage tonight after an unarmed African American teenager was
shot and killed. When that became a national story,
there was a lot of belly aching in the press.
How many people do we see killed in the United States about by the police each
year? How no one keeps accurate statistics.
There's currently no national statistics on police shootings,
law enforcement officer involved shootings.
And it struck me at the time that like what what we react to is all anecdotal.
You know, once in a while one of these things will catch fire, Tamir rice,
Jason Harrison, Sam Dubose bird will become sort of a national story.
And I personally was having trouble like processing that like number one,
is there a, is it trending one way or the other?
Are Police shooting more black people than white people? Just very simply. Yeah.
The problem is we don't know. We have no idea because nobody tracks these.
FBI doesn't state agencies don't for the most part so that that data doesn't
exist somewhere within the police department itself in the police department.
It does on the local level. However, uh,
it doesn't exist in any accurate way, uh, by a broader agency.
And I could tell you how many person [inaudible] there were in Florida in 2011
using the FBI numbers or the numbers submitted to the Florida Department of law
enforcement. But I can't tell you how many times police shot somebody. Now,
there have been a couple of organizations that have tried to keep track
nationally, but everything that's done so far is incomplete. You know,
cause most of those, you know, like the Guardian has an online database.
Most of them rely on media reports.
So they're only really keeping track of the ones that sort of hits the public
consciousness. That's right. So Ben and his editors thought,
let's do something that's more complete.
Let's do something that's unprecedented.
[inaudible]
so first study had Florida, it's the third biggest state.
Demographics are pretty similar to the rest of the country.
And Florida has wonderful public records laws. Legally,
it's easier to get information in Florida than in a lot of other places.
And so of course,
if government events sat down and started emailing every single police precinct
in the entire state of Florida,
I think I said 388 emails asking for five years worth of paper,
any paper generated when an officer fired a firearm and someone was injured or
killed as a result of that shooting. Now this involves a year of work.
How many police departments getting lawyers involved?
This is a massive thing that evolved. Probably no less than a hundred people.
But eventually, thank you sir.
Ben Put together the most comprehensive police shooting database that we know
of.
I want to show back a while back,
we sent our producer Matt Kielty down to the Tampa Bay Times. Oh,
is this them right here to check it out? Yeah. How many,
how many documents you think you have sitting on?
This desk is probably 5,000 pages.
I have a stack of paper that's um, about as tall as me, six feet tall.
We've got them broken down by county, but you can see, uh, so h a,
B bay county, Booker Aton, Boynton Beach, uh,
all the way through the alphabet. And you basically just have, uh, all these,
uh, Manila folders with tons of papers in them spread across an entire desk.
It's a combination of a use of force reports,
civil court records and media clippings. The represent,
uh, 831 shootings.
I hope every shooting in the state of Florida in, in, in six years time,
2009 to 2014. So we did was go through all of this material,
scrape each of those reports for every bit of information that we could get that
we thought was useful. Um,
circumstantial stuff did involve a swat team that involve, uh,
an armed suspect was there, chase all the demographic information for the,
the firing officer or officers and the people were hit by those bullets.
Then we thought, let's learn from these, let's see how,
how we can compile the data and build a database and um, you know,
hopefully draw some conclusions, some lessons, some solutions.
This is all going to go into it.
Sort of a giant online database at the Tampa Bay Times website.
Hopefully other organizations in other states will start to do the same.
Perhaps even one day we'll have a national agency that keeps track of this
stuff. In any case, in the meantime,
here's some of the things that Ben found and initially some of it, you know,
kind of surprised us. Well,
the biggest sort of counterintuitive a line in this, the,
the numbers are flat. He says,
if you look at the numbers of what you see year after year after year,
the numbers have stayed steady about 130 people shot by police every year,
which seems odd because a, you know, the past couple of years,
these videos that go viral and uh,
it makes it seem like this is a new and intense problem.
The numbers show that that doesn't seem to be the case.
We also broke these down into category. He says, you know,
what you see like on the most basic level, uh,
are that about a third of the police shooting cases involves someone on the
other side who is quote, mentally unstable.
And this is a case we're not taking a guess at whether the person is mentally
unstable.
These are cases in which there's some evidence in the report that the person has
been diagnosed mentally ill maybe off their meds at the time of the shooting.
And in that category,
Ben says they found a surprising of cases they call suicide by cop,
which is where it's somebody who's usually mentally ill,
is apparently trying to get themselves shot intentionally.
The person is in view of the police standing on a porch,
standing behind a screen door and raises a weapon toward the police,
either a weapon or, or what they want the police to think as a weapon.
So it's called I'm going to kill myself but I'm going to make you do it to me.
Right.
And that's considered a suicide attempt because they know they're going to get
shot. It's an attempt to incite the shooting. That's right.
This is something that people who cover police apparently know quite well.
You know, they're the news briefs that you see once or twice a week,
but it was news to us. I mean,
clearly police are now like the de facto frontline and dealing with mental
illness in this country. But when it got to bend central question,
what do the numbers say about race?
I think I would start with the fact that I'm there. I'm not sure.
It was so surprising that 40% of people shot by police are black.
And that is a, that is out of whack with, uh, the Florida, uh,
demographics. What is the percentage of African Americans in Florida?
It's not 40% it's more like 17 that's right.
Which means ultimately that if you're a black person in Florida,
you are four times as likely to be shot by police than if you're white.
So it doesn't tell so much right now,
but the breakdown between fatalities for the same demographics and as ways that
they're going through this particular set of numbers,
50.9% were carrying a firearm,
9% had a blade. Uh, 70% involve some form of resisting arrest. You know,
and we talked with them numerous times over two years, you know,
drilling down on those numbers and as we were doing that 50.9% you know,
it was weird, I started to feel like, you know,
I'm really glad that we have these numbers. Finally,
that in itself is a good thing,
but I'm further down 91 of the five 70 or 16 numbers themselves don't really get
you very far. 1% 16% this is 1% the more you hear, it's just like, yeah,
this is only one ultimately limited way of knowing the problem.
I mean, I mean, what's I guess to me is like how, I don't know,
it's back to where we were and why we wanted to start it.
[inaudible] nasty, nasty. I'm still just moved by the single cases,
the individual cases. And it's hard to remember that each of these is, you know,
I mean, they were all written in this, uh,
employment investigations revealed that ASP d officer Matthew Falor received a
call on this staccato sterile police speak.
Fowler approached department two 55 and was confronted by a white male later
identified as Anthony Skiles.
Armed with a knife at apartment two five five counts. Every one of these,
every report is at least one human life and someone was either, you know,
more often than not gravely injured or killed. Uh,
so we have on this table the investigation of the deaths or severe injury of 831
people
[inaudible]
so what did we decided to do in collaboration with the Tampa Bay Times is we
grabbed a couple of Folgers right off Ben Montgomery's giant folder stack to
follow wherever those stories might lead.
Matt guilty and Ben traveled around Florida on a few different occasions talking
to the people behind those statistics you heard.
And over the next couple of weeks we're going to bring you two of those stories.
This podcast is the first, um, Matt, I guess we'll just turn it over to you.
Yup. Okay. Uh, so day one. Yeah. Where was this place again? The land,
the Land Florida, Mr Down. It's hot, heavy,
low eighties little town on the east coast of Florida.
And we were there because Ben had found out about this event.
Do you even know what the thing is called?
It's the third they cause celebration.
The third anniversary celebration of the police killing of Marlon Brown.
Okay. And this event was being held at the West Felicia shrine club.
Try Club shrine club like Shriners,
like the Shriners just going to walk in and introduce myself.
So I walk in and you know, it's like a small community center,
linoleum floor fluorescent lights. And the first thing I noticed, to be honest,
is there's about 20 people in here, mostly black,
who were just milling about talking. But on the walls of this place,
I have photos of all the Shriners run, the length of this wall.
It's just like portraits of old white men wearing fez hats.
Who are all of the former Shriner presidents.
Just a old white dudes names like George Seger, Gunter language. Oh,
so all right. So Ben, and as I was taking in the scene,
this woman came up to me who was hosting the event. Her name is crystal Brown.
I do, I try to do something like this once a year from Molly's anniversary,
tall black woman, long dreads, and he's very piercing Hazel eyes.
And your relation to Marlin x. Y it was high school. We,
since I was 15 and I don't, I don't know Marlon Story. I don't. Um,
Marlon is, um, three years, May 8th, um,
he was 1230 in the morning and he was, um,
allegedly being stopped for not wearing a seatbelt. And so he didn't stop.
He got out of his car and he ran. Um, he was on,
I guess some kind of community control where he's supposed to be home by 12,
he was on probation for a drug charge. You've been caught with some painkillers.
So he ran and immediately the cop car followed him and eventually Marlin
slipped, fell the cop car, hit him going 24 miles. Power ran into him.
He was pinned under the car for about four or five hours. Four or five hours.
Yeah. Yup. And Crystal and some neighbors got out to the scene.
We sat out there and laid it for five hours until they were able to get the car
off. Marlin was pronounced dead.
And so crystal and I talked for a little bit and don't mind if I, uh,
join you for a minute. Is that okay?
I sort of just walked around and started introducing myself to people.
Where are you guys from in Florida? Tampa, Florida. Oh, you're from Tampa. Okay.
So we just made the drive and I don't quite know what I was expecting.
I guess I just thought it was, you know,
gonna be a local event for this one person. But as I started to meet people,
I started meet people from all over. From Tampa. From Palm Beach.
Whereabouts in New Yorker? Yeah.
I mean there were people from all over the country. East Flatbush, Brooklyn,
Chicago, Georgia, and yes, this is my son to Norris.
I started seeing these people who are wearing these tee shirts and pink shirt
and then you have two doves with a big picture of a young black man's face or a
name. Oh, they represent angels watching over me.
There was one woman with a picture of her son's eighth grade graduation photo on
her shirt. It's his cap and gown in red. He was 14 years old when he was killed.
He was also buried in this same cap in his gown and then another mother.
This is going on the fourth year,
so I have maybe about six or seven who had the name of her 23 year old son,
Rodney Mitchell on her shirt. I have one with his graduation picture on it.
I have like the fluorescent black and yellow one.
I have this Jamaican color one. I have a black and white.
I have different shirts. Oh yeah.
And I started seeing shirt after shirt after shirt and I'd say by the time like
40 people had showed up in there, all these different shirts,
I just realized like,
Oh, this is not just a thing for one person.
This is a network.
Like almost everyone there had lost either a cousin or a brother or a husband,
like even even a daughter to police violence. And in fact,
when I later spoke to one of those women you just heard,
I have one with his graduation picture on him just to touch a Clemens,
her 23 year old son, Rodney Mitchell,
he was shot and killed by police during a traffic stop.
We're actually going to get into that story later,
but she told me that I've met about 400 other mothers.
They've reached out to me and I 400 Oh yes. Really? Yeah.
Through like traveling around through Facebook.
I've met 400 other mothers who's lost their children. Wow.
I was just seeing like a fraction of that at this community center.
Got The scales. Surprising. Right.
And the other thing for me was how you see these stories pop up.
37 year old Alton Sterling, 40 year old Terence Crutcher,
at least the ones that get pulled up to a, like a national level.
And you see the family members come out,
which children who are dependent upon their daddy on a daily basis and for like
two days you see them on television. That big bad dude was my twin brother.
That big bat do was a father and then they kind of [inaudible] [inaudible] and
they're gone. And I guess what I've thought is, you know,
probably they have these long drawn out legal battles and then they go back to
their lives, whatever, like whatever that means. But instead it's like, oh no,
what happens is they get like folded up into this network [inaudible]
and we pray for those mostly is that, will you come into this family?
And so at the community center there was a moment of prayer where the 40 to 50
people sat down at these big round dining tables.
Because once upon a time ago,
there wasn't little coalition like some we have to do.
There was no way to know what to do.
There was no rule print on how to get justice or how to make changes and how to
protect our kids now loved ones and we use prayers and all
prayers in God's name. Amen. And so after the prayer,
crystal hollered from the back of the room for everybody to eat.
So everyone stood up and then the vibe just totally changed and somebody put on
some MJ and a lot of people started to crowd around these two big picnic tables.
He laid his mind just a, I'm not going to make now one comment until it oh no,
no, no, no comment. Which is where I met this woman.
I mean the only comment I was looking for was if you could just describe for me
what we got on the table. Cause I'm just a what's on a table. Yeah.
Just what's on the table this day. This table right here,
so I think you have changed. You have sweet tea, you have orange juice,
and then you have your condiments for that. But on the breakfast table, Oh man,
what's up? You get your eggs, you've got your grips, you get your bacon,
you've got your sausage, you got everything. You going to have to get nice,
good and full on today. Can I get your name? Sheila Geneva.
Reed Beal. I'm the mother of Sandra Blaine
in case you don't remember
like 10 2015 hello ma'am. What it takes,
I've told her reason for stop is you didn't fail.
You failed to signal your lane change. [inaudible] insurance for you.
Can you give me a few minutes? All right.
Senior plan is pulled over in a small town in Texas.
The cop runs her information, comes back to the car
putting out your cigarette. Please go mind. I'm in La Chi. What?
I put out my cigarette. You can step on out. Now.
I don't know if there's that baton might step out of the car,
step out of the car. No,
you don't have the right stepping out of the car and I have the right to do
that.
I do have the right condemn out or I will remove you and get it removed for a
failure out or I will remove you. I'm giving you a lawful order.
Don't touch me. Don't touch me. I'm not under arrest.
You have the right to say you are under arrest. Am I under arrest for what?
Get out of the car and then you go like shoe up. Get Out. Wow. No,
mentally Sandra gets out of the car for failure to signal.
You're doing all this fun over there for fun. You are bound to read my wrist.
Can you fucking
stop? No.
Sandra was eventually taken in jail. Four days later in that jail cell,
she was found dead hanged with a plastic garbage bag.
The death was ruled a suicide and Sandra's family disputed that ruling.
You got everything you want to have to get nice, good and full on today.
So I'm excited. Can I get your name? Sheila Geneva. Reed Beal.
I'm the mother of Sandra Blake. Sandra bland. Yeah. Where are you coming from?
Chicago. I want to let you, uh, eat your food.
I have one thing I wanted to ask to have you come,
have you come to events like this before? Yes sir. Quite a few.
I was in Missouri last week. Um, we go all around.
We try to support as many models as we can because it's important. And is that,
is that exactly like, is that what it is?
Is it really just like a support group? Yes sir. It's support.
It's support because that mother who has lost their baby needs to be able to see
somebody else who looks like them,
who's in the same situation that they are as opposed to someone walking up to
them and saying, I know how you feel, but you really don't.
Which made me think about something [inaudible]
Ben and I had talked about a lot,
which is in getting to meet these women and talk to these women,
you get the sense that their,
their experiences is really unique sort of loss.
It sucked to lose somebody to cancer.
I've lost a friend to cancer recently in fact is a horrible thing.
And a very, you know, 10,
10 times a hundred times worse for his first wife children than it is for me.
I think it's a different thing when your person is killed by another human being
and that human being is returned to the streets with a gun and a badge and a,
you know, in a position of authority.
And this is something that you do see in beds numbers,
even though the numbers themselves,
they can't really tell you whether or not a shooting was, was legally justified.
What is clear is that over 800 plus shootings,
even the shootings where the person was unarmed,
only one police officer has ever been charged.
So it's this weird sort of like double grief. Yeah.
It's like past and present at the same time.
Like you can't put it away because it's every day is another insult kind of.
Right.
Then it's soon as I'm happy again, this is crystal Brown. Somebody,
one of us is reaching out, whoever's psychosis, like they,
if something happened in, you know, here in Florida, we're in Florida,
we're gonna reach out to each other and then we're going to invite them and we
say this was like the, the club that nobody really wants to be a part of.
It's crazy, but it's his family. I said family is more than just blood.
This is my family and I could not have made it this way.
I put him still be fighting. I wouldn't be doing anything if it wasn't for them.
Okay. So after the event ended at the community center,
crystal took a bunch of the moms,
they all got in their cars and drove over to this like little gem shops.
Like do you guys do this after every,
every event or is this just like crystal knows this one says,
Krista knows this one's around here and has been telling everyone about this.
This is deandre Joseph. Her Son Andrew died in 2014 so no,
we didn't know anything about this,
but figured this must be part of the different type of learning.
This is a part of just coping and dreaming. Right, right.
We're all just simply trying to find our way.
It's a crystal gathered like probably 15 of us into this tiny little store
because she wanted to show these women like here's how I cope or here's how I
deal with my grief. You can either get the um,
the large stage at certain point cause it was talking to these two women and she
just had this big bundle of sage in her hand. Okay. Yeah.
Cause like if you want to do like your house, like a, like a,
like some deep shit.
Like then I opened my windows and I just usually I go through my house,
she says to sage, calms her down and I'm just,
and then uh, they went from the gem shop over to Crystal's house, maybe
mid size, one story house in and
lot of women hung out in the living room. We're drinking juice,
talking to Ben about his story. Crystal and her cousin were in the kitchen,
cook them chicken,
the other guy look good as a day. Yeah.
And one thing that caught me by surprise is how these women,
when they come together and they like,
they bring with them and have their own stories, these stories of grief, of,
of suffering. And yet when they're in the same room together,
it's like they just, they just have fun.
[inaudible]
apparently the night before they'd all gone out dancing together.
[inaudible] fire.
And now what we're doing, instead of getting motel rooms again,
this is Natasha Clemons, we starting to stay over here at each other's houses.
We've lived in each other's bed on each other's couch, you know, air mattresses.
It becomes like a huge sleepover and versus let's go on and sleep for up
talking, you know, getting to know each other. You know,
tell me stories about his age, his children. So it's like therapy for us.
Fake, he's letting me pass.
But there was this moment when I spent the day with these women that really
stuck with me, I believe were ad, I'm sorry, Ireland Brown's death.
And it was when crystal led some of us over to the site where her ex husband,
Marlin, was hit by that squad cars.
It's about 12 people here and about eight of them were women who had lost either
a husband or a brother or a child.
And we were basically just in someone's backyard just walking through this
patchy grass.
So when you see the video that's pretty, that we did came down,
that's the video, that's the street. Then
house probably over like right there.
And then the police car that came behind him was probably right here.
And then the officer that hit that hit him, came in
and then we come on.
That's when he came in. He came right here.
And that's why we call it the execution and the vegetable garden because the
garden was here and vegetables were growing and that they had onions then cause
um, when they, when they, you know,
when they took him away and released it and took down and tape and stuff,
we came back here. That's all you could smell. What's uneasy.
And so now like when you cut, ain't like, it's, it's not as,
it's not as bad now, but just the association like school,
when I'm cutting onions, you get that smell. Like it just, you get those floods
[inaudible] in your car. It just brings you right back here. [inaudible].
Yup.
And the 12 is just kind of stood there for a minute.
Crystal size. We're starting to get teary.
Some of the other women's started to cry
and then y'all want me to do a take some? Yeah. My phone ain't the best.
A lot of what? A better phone than me. A couple of women handed me their phones.
Mine is broken. Oh look like it's going to do right, but,
and it's probably about these eight women who huddled together and they just
stared at the camera with this sort of straight face. All right. Three,
two, one
and then let me, three, two, one.
All right, thank you. I think we got them
and we all started walking back up to the cars. Bristle.
I just want to thank you for just sharing that with us because I know
it has to be pretty hard to even come back to the Saturday. Yeah, I can go.
Yeah. We haven't been on hand a long. It's been awhile. Oh,
we'll go to the grave site.
We used to go there once a week at night,
three o'clock in the morning. That's why I remember Dan.
I used to tell you all the time, how do you live so far away from him?
Oh my God, that was it. That was my son's grave.
It's about 15 minutes tops from where I live.
Every time I visited home I have to go there and spend some time. Oh
yeah. No boys. How could you not?
Right.
And Ain't ain't no goofy. Like you want to go take a chair and sit there. Yeah.
And it's crazy cause like it's a whistle if a cemetery like a little bit further
out and it's crazy.
You can go by there like a certain time every day and it's this little white
man. He's chair everything like set up. Like he literally, I think he does.
He like go have lunch with every day I dance to be [inaudible].
It's the cemetery that's way out like going on towards Popeye's and all of that.
It's a little white guy that's always sitting out there. He take his chair.
I can have a wholesaler, I would think. I know it was not the happen.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
so that trip to Florida was almost about a year ago and I feel like I happen to
be there at this really interesting moment because just a few months after that
trip,
[inaudible]
a Geneva Reed [inaudible] who was the mother of Sandra Bland who I met,
she spoke at the Democratic National Convention one year ago
yesterday. I let the
worst nightmare anyone could imagine.
She was on stage with Michael Brown's mother, Eric Garner's mother.
I've watched as my daughter was lowered into the ground and it was around this
time that a few of these women's started to call themselves the mothers of the
movie.
When you say about the movement,
some of them showed up at the women's march in d c
[inaudible]
and um, it was weird because in this short amount of time,
this thing that we had stumbled into this thing that really kind of felt like at
the time of support group had suddenly become a force
[inaudible]
coming up, hey, put it down. A cop with a gun, a man with a knife,
put it down.
And I look at the razor thin life or death moment between them.
Are you going to get it again?
So stay with us.
This is Christopher calling from south Florida.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich and just,
let's just pick right back up with our,
our story from Florida with Tampa Bay Times you're put at Ben Montgomery and our
own mad guilty. All right, so day two,
day two was Daytona led 53, May 3rd Daytona Beach, Daytona beach.
It's about everything.
And what happened was we went to this thing was these women,
mostly black who have lost people to police violence.
And I'm time sitting across the table from an African American city councilman
in Daytona Beach. And I told him what I had been working on.
I told him some of the numbers we'd learned and he said,
you really need to meet our police chief. Uh,
you guys want me to run down to get a shower since you got here?
His name is Mike Chitwood. You're not cool now. Just, yeah, just a microphone.
Okay. He's the police chief of Daytona Beach,
known for its wild and rocket spring break scenes.
They have bike week that draws 500,000 bikers from all over the country,
Daytona international speedway. And on top of that,
the permanent population there is like 62,000 people and over that six year
period they've only had four police shootings. And that's slow.
Yeah. For a city like that, that's really low. Jesse.
I need the breakdown for 2015 and in fact while we were there by race of tickets
and arrest, [inaudible] had his assistant print out these spreadsheets.
Here we go. Those there. The stats. Yup. Thank you.
Have to do the math and especially,
it's actually kind of fascinating because if you look at them,
you just can go right down here and you can add them up for things like
aggravated, aggravated assault, theft, shoplifting, a speeding or arrest ratio.
And our ticket ratio basically mirrors our city in terms of racial demographics.
Yeah, we're right. We're roughly a 60, 40, shitty, 60% white,
40% African American. And so when you look at these numbers,
it's pretty much what you see tickets for speeding about 60,
40 arrest for theft about 60, 40.
That's the way we're supposed to in theory approach to law.
And so what are they doing differently? Well, a whole bunch of things.
First of all, when all these, these incidents were occurring in, uh,
around the country with Ferguson and everything else, we did a race in policing,
mandatory training for the entire PD.
And basically what we wanted our officers to do is number one,
to learn the history of the country.
Cause the history of the country is that we are a racist nation no matter how
you want to look at it and started with moving the Indians off of their land for
manifest destiny. Uh, when you look at Jim Crow laws,
when you look at the civil war, we look at slavery.
When you look in the bull Connor, for example,
of turning the dogs and fire hoses loose on civil rights marchers.
So it's important for officers to understand that,
that you may go into an African American community and you may think and act and
talk away where you think you're being respectful and understanding.
But in reality you're not.
But let's not for a moment think that there isn't biased in policing because
there's biased. We all have biased Ines. Uh, and the trick is,
and I don't know no of to trick and I don't know of any of us know how to
contain that.
How do we stop that bias from coming through when you make a decision? Right.
And I think in, you know,
I've read a lot about implicit bias and it always seems like, um, it's like a,
it's like feels like a kinder way to say fear, like a fear of a black person.
And that fear is greater than what you would feel when you're encountering a
white person, when you're out on the job as a cop.
When you look at some of the shootings that were caught on video and I,
and I think of the poor school janitor who lost his life in Minnesota. Oh yeah.
The [inaudible] Casteel shooting.
There's a guy who told the officer in no uncertain terms, I'm a good guy.
I have a gun permit. You can't get a gun permit if you're a convicted felon,
you can't get a gun permit if you're a drug dealer.
So when the minute that young man tells that officer,
I have a gun permit for some unknown reason,
that officer threat level with a baby in the car and I got a guy in is what his
kid, his girlfriend and Carney's tell him he's a gun permit holder. This is,
this is an easy car stop for some reason.
And the reason is because of the color of the man's skin.
All of those things never registered.
Black guy reaching for his black because pocket.
And I shoot and I would like to tell you in all my years in policing,
I would like to sit here and be naive and tell you that we don't shoot harm
people as a 28 year practitioner in law enforcement, a second generation cop.
I'm appalled at what I see on those videos.
I could not believe that my profession in some cases is that out of control.
Some of them I understand what's going on. I mean,
you're wrestling into ground for your life and you and you know there are times
that we have to use deadly force, but the incidents in South Carolina,
the incident in Minnesota, I mean, are you kidding me?
And you're looking at what are we doing? I mean, how do you,
how do you train that out of an officer so that when they make a traffic stop,
they're not already operating with this level of heightened fear or this
perceived threat? In my opinion. Number one, you have to train tactically sound.
You have to train using it.
Real life scenarios that take that extra split. Second,
before you fire your weapon. And I'll give you an anecdotal rup very quickly.
When I first joined the Philadelphia Police Department,
we were shooting people at a crazy rate on an accidental discharge.
The officer had their finger on the trigger.
When they would go to grab that person, if that person pulled or moved,
you would jerk back and it was a natural reaction to squeeze the trigger.
So they sent us all back up to the police academy and we all had our be
retrained on how to keep your finger on the side plate of the weapon,
not on the trigger. So that if that happened,
you wouldn't accidentally trip and fire and shoot somebody and you went to
thought it was Armageddon. Oh my God, they're gonna get us killed. One reality,
what it did was it slowed down your field division. It slowed everything down.
That split second didn't make a difference in that blink of an eye didn't make a
difference. It made a difference in you not shooting because that split second,
let you see what you thought may have been the the color of my glass coming out
and my cell phone was a cell phone
so you buy yourself a little bit of time and this is the thing that chip wood
comes back to again and again is this idea of time in certain situations,
slow down when you're dealing with a mentally ill person,
slow down like whatever you can do, he was covered.
Just creates some space to buy yourself another 30 seconds,
that extra 30 seconds maybe the difference between saving your life and somebody
else's life. Another interesting thing was,
and Ben Ben found this out also through some of his reporting with other police
chiefs is the idea that some police chiefs don't like to hire kids out of high
school, like 1920 year olds in part because everything I do is this.
It texts a lot.
It's all know how to communicate. It's like this. And then when,
when they look up and go to talk to somebody, I'm,
and I'm serious about the ones that the drive through a McDonald's and they
could piss off the person ordering cheeseburger. How the, how did you do it?
It's just their demeanor. It's just the way they act.
In fact,
Ben told me that he talked to different police chief who told him the young
people who are coming into the academy, uh,
the past few years have never been in a physical fight,
which is a problem because when they get into a fight,
their heart starts to race and their muscles tense up and they don't really know
what to do.
So they freak out and they're way more likely to draw a weapon and use the
weapon to, you know, to, to in the confrontation. Huh. So how do you,
do you like you can't ask her how many times have you beat somebody up or been
beaten up on your nose and nose? So that Ben says that,
that's why the police chief told him he looks to hire bouncers.
I see bouncers for chip Wade, he said from, I'm
just my little myopic world that I live in.
We have an awful high number of men and women who served in the military.
They are my best officers. They are level headed, they are well trained.
They know how to follow the policy
basically.
You know how to not freak out during the confrontation and last thing provinces,
the last thing, one of the most
important things too.
It says you have to get into the community and I'm not talking about the the
good stuff. Oh we they bought Christmas gifts or they cook Thanksgiving dinner.
I'm talking day to day. You have to get to know people.
Yeah. Cool. All right. Sure. And so to make this point, Chitwood got up,
walk me down the hall to another office.
Sat me down in a computer. Sound comes on about 20 seconds. Okay.
To show me this video. There you go.
So video starts in silence and it's a body cam video.
It's a body cam on the cop who is driving a squad car.
He's got his body cameras mounted to his eye on his glasses to the cameras going
where his eyes go next to him. Passenger side is his partner.
Both cops are white also it's night. So
okay.
Call is for a guy who was running around with a knife trying to stab people who
was off his meds. I think he was on a crack cocaine binge,
if I remember correctly. They Park.
It's a little neighborhood street and you can see down the street,
half a block away. No Man, I was this shirtless black guy.
Why don't you chill out there? That's the cop talking to him.
The cop where in the body cam and this black man,
he's got his arm raised pretty big knife in his hand and he's walking towards
the cops. You stopped talking so crazy
like it gets closer and closer and closer and finally the copper and the body
cam pulls out the Taser.
The other officers out of the frame is behind him with his firearm out and the
guy what you're fucking like put it down.
Approaching, approaching, approaching, approaching.
Well you're not getting the knife down. Put it down.
He gets within like 10 feet of the cops,
Taser, Taser, Taser taker.
The guy with buddy campfires, the Taser, the guy holding the knife,
he falls onto his back onto this cement driveway.
Still got the knife in his hand.
Dan, are you going to get it again? Put it down. Are you going to get it again?
And the cop who's got his gun out, he hustles over,
kicks the knife out of the guy's hand, grabs him by the hand, turns him over,
right?
And then he's been trying central coast for cuffs,
him and then [inaudible] Derek, man, it's not a,
it's not a smart idea to have a knife coming at the police.
The officer will say,
why didn't you listen to me and just dropped the knife and walked her. Me.
Why did you keep coming at me
real lucky you didn't get shot. I want it. I was trying not to lose.
Trying your best to get shot. I'll see you down here. You want to die?
I want to see you wanna die. Huh? You can die.
He tells the officer goes,
I'm Jesus Christ and I want everybody to know the police boats can't kill
[inaudible] all right, there we go on stand up. Alright, count to three. One,
two, three. And so the two cops pick them up, walk them over to the squad car,
put them in
in the video lens. Huh? So this is the thing that you guys,
will you use this video for? What exactly? One
of multitude of videos that we show officers in the correct way to do things.
You know, and,
and that's the points we hit home are the officers use time and distance to
their advantage.
They didn't pull right up and the guidleines in the car and tried to stab.
When I'm in Uni, you have to resort to deadly force right away.
They use verbal commands first warn and let them know what's going on. Uh,
trigger control was another thing. You know what? That Taser, Taser, Taser,
and this is important because the guy's partner was holding a gun.
Had he heard this,
you might've just instinctively reacted thinking it was a gunshot and fired his
gun.
So you know he's deploying the Taser and communication is key communication with
the person you're trying to arrest in communication with your fellow officers
because those are the things that we drive home. And again,
there was no doubt in my mind that they,
one officer in particular knew that individual from prior contact. Right.
I mean it's interesting to hear him say the name Derek, right?
It's like Derrick is Derrick and Derrick isn't just a black man shirtless with a
knife in his hand when there's no connection there.
It's a lot easier to see somebody as nameless and faceless and I got scared and
I shot him. But because of that,
knowing that officer because of that and establish some kind of a rapport that
made the officer think of how he's going to deal with this thing.
[inaudible]
actually after we finished watching them video and I was packing up Chit with
told me that just a couple months after that incident on bike and through the
neighborhood and you might man sit on the front step waves at me. Hey you,
what are you doing man? It did. Derrick does. Yeah. You stupid son of a bitch.
You don't know how close you came to being dead,
but he's back on his medication,
wasn't doing drugs and he was as completely as normal as me.
And you are right now.
[inaudible]
no, again, uh, almost kind of like when I was with these women,
it felt like I was just in Daytona at this specific moment because it was just a
few months after I left
last night's primary election. Among the big winners.
Daytona beach is police chief. He is now Belushi county's new sheriff.
Well, Mike Chitwood was elected the sheriff of Volusia County.
Humble. I am extremely honored,
which is the county that Daytona beach belongs to. Huh.
And the other thing to mention is that, uh,
chipper belongs this organization called Perf,
which is the police executive research forum.
It's this big coalition of police chiefs and in 2016 per put out what they
called her,
30 guiding principles for the use of force and the number one principle, well,
rather than being something law and order law and order is the sanctity of human
life. Hmm. Now just a month after proof put out those principles.
Two of the biggest policing organizations in the world, the ICP,
the International Association of Chiefs of Police and the fraternal order of
police.
The big police in union both came out against these guiding principles,
basically saying that being a cop is a dangerous job and some of these
principles make it more dangerous.
And then just like eight months later or so, um,
the ICP and the fraternal order of police started to adopt some of these
principles. Hmm. Despite that,
there still is a bit of a divide between the organizations,
but according to Ben, for the very first time,
I think you're seeing these massive conversations and police weren't talking
about this two or three years ago. Huh. I don't know man.
And just thinking about this,
like you've got these women who have become kind of a political force.
You have also this growing movement of cops who are possibly changing the way
policing is done in America, or at least maybe slowly. Right.
But cumulatively it does. I hesitate to use this word, but it does make,
it does feel like reason for hope. Right.
And I sort of felt the same way too, but
there was this experience than I had registered,
realized how far hope has to go.
We are here to see Natasha Clemons. Natasha Clemons,
the mother of Rodney Mitchell. Okay.
So in touch with a woman who you heard earlier,
I'm back at the community center.
I've met 400 other mothers who lost their children.
That's actually when I first met her.
Men had been reporting on Natasha for like a couple of years by this point.
And we were there because Ben was going to hand a ton of documents over to
Natasha on her son Rodney's case, cause she didn't have any.
And I was there because we'd set up a short interview with Natasha.
But when we got to her door,
she just started sobbing.
And then I just had no idea what had happened.
But then usually I just turn the tape recorder off. Huh. So what was,
what was happening in that moment? Well. Okay, so the backup.
So meeting somebody like Chitwood, you know, um,
like there is a sort of hope in that I believe. But the thing about, uh,
Chitwood, um, uh,
sheriff a police chief is that the only have the power to fire a police officer.
And that's really about it. After that, it goes into the court system.
And so for Natasha, um, her son, Rodney, 23 years old,
unarmed was shot and killed by two police officers during a traffic stop after
the shooting, a judge ruled that the two officers had done nothing wrong.
They had acted in accordance with the law.
And it just so happened that 45 minutes before Ben and I showed up at her,
she just got an email from her lawyers saying that the appeal that she had filed
against that decision, uh, had just been rejected.
And so we sat there in Natasha's apartment for awhile.
We actually even left for like an hour, eventually came back,
kind of just hit reset on the whole thing. Mentally. Natasha,
show me some pictures of Romney, long dreads. He's got a big, big smile.
Big Smile, right? White smile. And then we sat down in her kitchen table. Um,
okay. So, uh, if you can walk me back to the night,
that kind of everything. Everything happened
and shown 11, 2012, Natasha was at home,
nine 30 at night, Rodney who was 23 years old,
was back from college and out driving and touch car.
That's when all the phone calls started happening. People calling,
saying something's going on with your car. I knew something was wrong.
So I immediately started screaming outside to see if I can get somebody to,
you know, respond to help me so I can get a ride. Nobody came, came out.
So I started running down the interstate barefoot. I just left.
I don't even recall locking the door or anything like that.
Eventually a family member actually picks her up. They drive to the scene,
she gets there, it looks like just people everywhere, police cars.
And I was like, where's Rodney?
I was looking for my vehicle and my one cousin says, [inaudible],
he's over there.
She pointed about 20 feet over to where the car had come to a stop.
And it collided with a gas station,
but then she had the the back of my loop on my pants so that I couldn't run over
there.
The whole place was surrounded by a police tape and eventually Natasha says it
took a couple of hours,
but a cop pulled her off to the side and told her that her son had been shot and
killed by police. I just got on my knees, hands and knees, and started praying.
Don't let this speech roll please, Lord. I was basically big and in pleading,
that's the only thing I could to what, what else do you do? Is Cry,
scream, pray, Christ, scream, pray, cry, scream, pray. Next thing you know,
I woke up, I was at the hospital.
Natasha says that she apparently was so frenzy,
did that an EMT on the scene struggled with something to calm me down.
So when I woke up, I see my family standing over me in the hospital.
You know, as to what happened to Rodney that night,
Ben has looked at testimony from the cops involved from eyewitnesses,
different court records to piece together the events. You know, Rodney,
according to all these documents that night,
Rodney and his 60 year old cousin were in Natasha's car.
They had stopped at a gas station.
They left the gas station and were driving down this, uh,
highway when he and his little cousin, uh, get pulled over by two, uh,
white officers. The officer said he saw him without a seatbelt.
It turns out Rodney was wearing a seatbelt and these two officers approaches
vehicle one is kind of standing in front of the car about several feet away
towards like the driver's side.
And the officer approaches his window according to Rodney's cousin, he says,
boy, why didn't you pull over sooner? And uh,
and then orders Rodney to put the car in park.
And Ronnie's got both hands at this point on the steering wheel and reaches down
to put the car in park.
And this is where things in the story sort of diverge because the cops say that
Rodney put the car in park but then quickly put it back into drive accelerated
at the officer in front of the car.
Ronnie's cousin gives two conflicting accounts as to what happened.
And there was apparently an eye witness across the street who said the car had
yet to move, but what is clear is what happened next,
which is deputy and front pulls out his gun fires two shots,
and in the windshield, the deputy right by the door. Here's the fire.
He pulls a gun and fires twice. One bullet went through Rodney's left hand,
which he'd put up in Self-defense.
Another bullet entered through his left temple and the car lurches forward and
Corinne's across the street for about 300 yards until it collides with this gas
station. Rodney's cousin at this point gets out of the car fleets from the scene
unharmed. Eventually paramedics arrive in pronounced Rodney dead at the scene.
My mind is always on Rodney. Natasha says, when she does think about that night,
she always comes back to this one question. Why were the guns pulled?
Why? Why? What? Why was that? What was that all about?
What do you think the answer is? He's black and that's just it.
Is there ever a moment where you try and put yourself in the mind of those two
officers? Absolutely not because I would never do somebody kid like that.
That never crossed. No, I would never do that. Do you feel like it's like,
do you feel like the cop in that moment it's Rodney's black is what frightens
the cop and that's why he pulls his gun out? No, he's the bully. Hell if he,
if somebody gets hurt, he doesn't mind. He gets injured or killed,
he's going to get off. He's behind that blue badge. She's a bully.
Is that what you think of cops like writ large? That's how it is.
That's exactly how it is. Nope. EFMs and buts about it.
Cause it's hard for me cause I think like,
like it's clear that there's discrimination that exists within the police force
and the people who they are sworn to protect and serve.
But like at the end of the day there's probably a hand like, well I don't know,
I couldn't give you a percentage but a number of officers in which like yes they
are probably violent individuals who don't belong in a police force.
But I would assume that like a majority of the cops mean well have probably
probably have some sort of bias where they don't think I see a black person and
I'm going to like, I'm going to get that boy. But that there's like a,
like there's some sort of triggered response and that the police are constantly
being put into different situations where they feel under threat and concerned
and that like,
there's like a whole host of factors leading to these moments where somebody is
shot and killed. It's not just that they're out here bullying people.
You say that because you're, you're white.
That's why you say that. I'll tell you what, I'll tell you what,
we can try this, go to my sister, we'll make sure we can get your week,
go to tennis lawn, get yourself spree black,
and I guarantee you you'll get a different response. I dare you try it.
I bet you we could make you look like a a black boy. I'm telling you,
you'll see a huge difference. And that's just it.
Like sitting, like sitting there in that moment, I,
I felt I felt the Gulf
and [inaudible]
I just kept wondering like,
how long does it take to fill that golf? Like how many Chitwood's does it take?
Uh, how many conversations need to happen
in any case? Um,
do you want us to then still had to give Natasha those files on Rodney to get
those documents for you? I would appreciate it. Sure. Okay.
Yeah. Sorry.
So Ben grabbed this huge folder of paper out of the trunk of our car,
walked back inside. This is not everything.
Um, Ben put the stack of Rodney's files on this glass kitchen table.
So again, with the stack, um, uh,
like 10, uh, crime scene photos,
because I don't want to be the person, uh,
to give you those unless you want me to go get them right now.
But there, you know,
I don't want to, I won't have it.
I don't wanna retraumatize you and their graph, just frankly the graphics,
you know, so, um,
I'll leave it up to you. You don't have to tell me right now.
Yeah. When I'm ready, I'll get them.
[inaudible] and I'm going to have to eventually see, yeah,
three days later.
And Atocha contacted Ben and said that she was ready to see those photos.
Wow.
[inaudible]
uh, [inaudible]
huge thanks to Ben monk,
I mean at the Tampa Bay times and to the staff at the paper that,
that did all the hard work of gathering statistics and material in the near,
near future. They're going to be putting out Ben Story,
a whole series of videos and interactive graphic with all their final numbers.
It should be amazing. Definitely check it out. Well,
we'll make sure that we link to it when it's live from our website,
radiolab.org and then of course to our own Med guilty who reported and produced
this piece. Next week we'll bring you part two of, ah,
Matt Kielty and Ben Montgomery's reporting to very different kinds of story.
A check in for that. Okay. Um, chat app and Ron,
I'm Robert Krulwich. Thanks for listening.